Time magazine celebrated its 100 most
influential people with a gala in New
York City last night's party prominently
featured the leaders of social movements
that are reshaping this country the
honorees made history for their youth
and gender diversity Adriana Diaz had
one of the best seats on the red carpet
so you get to see everybody going in the
door Adriana good morning good morning
Gail I saw everybody up close this
year's list featured activists actors
singers and athletes the celebration
brought together some of the most
accomplished people across industries
under one roof this year's time 100 most
influential list was a convergence of
cultural figures just an incredible
honor and I'm just grateful to be on the
list
with a record number of women and young
people honored from parkland student
activists to stranger things actress
Millie Bobby Brown who at 14 is the
youngest to ever make the list is a
little intimidating I'm here to be a
looky-loo all eyes were on performer
Jennifer Lopez who made the list for the
first time the night's honorees shared
their recognition I raise my glass to
survivors tirana burke is the activist
who turned the me - hashtag into a
movement it means a lot it means a lot
to be able to represent survivors around
the world and say that we're visible and
we're here we have something to say and
contribute to this moment I'm very proud
of a lot of different people for
speaking out I think it's absolutely
incredible some of those featured like
figure skater Adam rip Han this is the
first time I really thought oh my god
this is crazy and President Obama's
official portrait artist Kehinde Wiley
said the honor left them in awe I didn't
even know that things like this were
possible and it's a true testament to
the power of art in the transformative
power of America oh what a night what a
night it was so how was JLo because he
told us on the red carpet that she was
one of the people you wanted yeah
because you know I've never seen her
perform in person she killed as she
always does and for us it was a group
field trip I think it's an honor just to
be
invited I think it's an honor because
either there's people there you want to
meet or people you already know there's
always somebody interesting and I liked
hanging with J Lo's mom yes she's mrs.
Lopez who said she watches us every
morning so thank time mrs. Lopez